has come centuries from now almost all  humans have lost the ability to see some  say sight was taken from them by God to  heal the earth for the few who remain  vision is only a myth but after so many  years the power of sight has returned  sometimes different children they have  the ability to see  [Music]  my children they have the power that we  would call magical or evil must protect  them  for centuries we feared this day would  come  the evil of light once almost destroyed  the world  and it has returned find the children  who can't see  and bring some to me now if we kill the  babies they might leave us alone no I  stand with bah-bah-bah  [Music]  he's total our gift  they will bring knowledge that will  begin a new world  our family we are one we fight as one  [Music]  I have to keep you safe below it has  come  it's astonishing how the smallest moment  can change an entire world  you